Вважаєте, що лише російські ЗМІ є пропагандистськими?
І промивають мізки глядачам?
Погляньте, як регіональні ЗМІ в Україні агітують за кандидатів у президенти.
Ось Перший Ізмаїльський канал повторює риторику російських ЗМІ
про фашистів у Києві.
Журналісти ностальгують за СРСР
та дякують за концерт, організований кандидатом.
"Ти хохол, а я узбек, а земля одна"
Те, як кандидат потішив виборців концертом,
улюблена тема сюжетів у регіонах.
А ще - як кандидат з "простими" людьми поспілкувався...
"Простими" вулицями міста пройшовся ...
"попив славної трускавецької "Нафтусі" в бюветі"
поїв у "звичайній" їдальні заводу:
"не оминув заводську їдальню та перевірив, як годують працівників"
- Ну, давайте борщу скуштуємо!
Інтерв’ю з кандидатами в регіональних ЗМІ часто дуже лояльні -
без гострих запитань і критики.
І подекуди - взагалі ані про плани, ані про програму кандидата.
- Ви знаєте, я вас слухаю і розумію, що Біблія - це, мабуть, ваша настільна книга.
Що таке влада? Це жертва? Служіння людям?
Натомість навіть у новинах регіональні ЗМІ
замість об'єктивності або хвалять кандидата.
"Юлія Тимошенко - єдиний кандидат, що має чітку ґрунтовну програму".
Або скочуються до маніпуляцій
Не минається і без класичних візуальних прийомів:
пустити голубів у небо
або роздати подарунки
- От скажіть, коли востаннє вам вручали подаруночки?
- От бачите, ото Ляшка все життя будете згадувати.